our economic system informs almost
everything about how people relate to
each other and to government and to
corporations in the United States
so here is our deep dive into capitalism
socialism what these terms mean
social democracy sometimes considered
the happy medium between capitalism and
socialism and much more the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
for years now I've been talking about
the difference between Democratic
socialists and Social Democrats and I
don't want to redo the entire analysis
again but to sort of like top line it
for you the real difference is that
Democratic socialists are socialists
where Social Democrats are not right the
democratic socialism is socialism in the
sense that it includes socializing the
means of production social democracy is
what's sometimes called a blended
economy it's called well regulated
capitalism private ownership of
businesses remains but there's a very
heavy focus on using tax revenue for a
strong social safety net using
progressive taxation to ensure people
don't get left behind that we properly
fund healthcare and education and so on
and Bernie Sanders has a long history of
calling himself Democratic Socialist and
he may well come from sort of democratic
socialist lines of thought but Bernie's
platform today is not a democratic
socialist platform Bernie's platform in
2016 was not a democratic socialist
platform
he is a social democrat now I'm not
criticizing Bernie because he can't be a
Democratic Socialist because he
shouldn't be a Democratic Socialist he
can be whatever he wants to be but it is
truly becoming self-destructive for
Bernie Sanders to refer to himself as a
Democratic Socialist when he's not
because it allows the right-wing smear
merchants and the attacks on Bernie
related to Venezuela and Stalinist type
communism or Cuba or whatever even as a
Democratic Socialist those attacks would
be stupid and misguided but the the the
reality is that those are allowed to be
more successful by virtue of Bernie
referring to himself as a Democratic
Socialist now there are people who are
going to hear me say this and they'll
write in and they'll say you know David
the terms have become interchangeable
Social Democrat and Democratic
socialists in modern American politics
it's sort of the same thing this is
really a semantic disagreement semantics
is exactly why this matters right I
agree with you I
saying there is a hang-up here about
socialism and communism these are
politically loaded terms nobody benefits
from this confusion and Bernie should be
saying I'm a social democrat in the
style of the Nordic countries and
Denmark and similar countries in the
style of the the Swedish social
democracy of the early 20th century for
example these are capitalist countries
that have decided we are going to use
the fruits of the economy not to allow
unfettered out-of-control inequality and
a shrinking middle class at the expense
of the super-rich becoming even
wealthier but these are capitalist
countries that have said we are going to
use the fruits of the economy to make
sure that we raise people's standard of
living that we provide health care to
everybody that we properly regulate
industry which does not have an
incentive to regulate itself that's the
Bernie platform right the the platform
is social democracy not democratic
socialism and the only defense of Bernie
calling himself a Democratic Socialist
is that the meaning of democratic
socialism has changed and that's not a
very good argument okay most people
don't know what socialism actually is
they don't know the difference between
socialism and communism they don't know
the difference between any of these
terms let's not make it easier for them
to muddy the waters by using the wrong
term or misunderstanding what it is that
Bernie Sanders is we have to contend
with the reality that we have
unfortunately uninformed or in most
cases poorly informed Society in the
United States half the country doesn't
vote most people are totally unaware
about basic realities of this sort don't
make it easier for them to to
misunderstand what it is that bernie is
doing by using the wrong terms so here's
my request to you contact the Bernie
campaign tweet them go to their website
whatever tell them Bernie
stop saying Democratic Socialist say
social democrat I agree with the
platform of social democracy that's
Bernie's platform let's use that term
and if you disagree with my analysis
write to me and tell me what's the
upside of Bernie calling himself a
Democratic Socialist when he's actually
not espousing a democratic socialist
platform I'm actually open to having my
mind changed I posted on Twitter earlier
today at D Pakman what are strong
arguments for why Bernie should call
himself a Democratic Socialist even
though he's not the argument that the
meaning of the terms has sort of changed
or become muddled or gray that's a bad
argument I disagree with that argument
but if you have other arguments to make
I want to hear from you I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman and the show is on Twitter
at David Pakman show okay I want to
start today with a fact check along
similar lines to others that we've done
in the past we have been talking a lot
about democratic socialism versus social
democracy and in today's interview we're
actually going to have a conversation
about when we say that we have a
capitalist system what version of a
capitalist system do we actually have
it's not just unfettered total
free-market capitalism and that's going
to be more of a philosophical discussion
but in practice one of the confusions
that has been prevalent among political
pundits and people who talk about
economics is that Denmark and Norway and
Finland and Sweden are not socialist
economies they are mixed economies they
are a well regulated form of capitalism
that has decided to prioritize social
welfare programs in terms of funding via
taxation in contrast to other countries
like the United States which have not
made those social welfare programs the
same type of priority and there's a
graphic that's been spreading virally
about Norway which number one calls
Norway democratic socialist that's one
issue
and number two makes a bunch of specific
statistical claims comparing and
contrasting Norway to the United States
sort of making the case that Norway is a
quote socialist paradise of some kind so
let's look at the graphic and the
comparison and if you're just listening
I'll tell you a bunch of what's on it
and the graphic claims the
in Norway's democratic socialist system
there's a lower poverty rate and a
higher life expectancy than in the
United States that infant mortality is
lower and there's a lower murder rate
and there's less incarceration and a
higher GDP per capita and workers are
more protected by unions the country is
happier they have free health care and
free higher education higher
homeownership rate the minimum wage is a
living wage rather than a poverty wage
more vacation more parental leave and
all with only the slightest increase in
tax rate 38.5% average personal tax rate
in Norway versus a 37 percent average
personal tax rate in the United States
now if you have a sense of any of these
particular metrics you might see that
graphic and realize that some of those
don't really sound quite right the idea
of an average tax rate what are we
talking about the median are we talking
about an effective tax rate or a
marginal tax rate there's a lot of stuff
in there that doesn't make immediate
sense so when we see a viral image like
this making an argument that Norway is
socialist and is better off than the
United States in always the first thing
you need to do is figure out whether the
numbers it presents are correct then you
need to answer the question about
whether Norway is actually socialist and
only once you do that can you really
make a sort of qualitative analysis to
evaluate the claim that socialist Norway
is better off than unfettered capitalist
United States so let's look first at
some of the numbers that the the image
claims it says for example that Norway's
poverty rate is 10 percent and the US
poverty rate is 29 percent I'm not
finding that information the information
I found based on the Census Bureau is
that the poverty rate in the United
States just a year and a half ago was
twelve point three percent and that
Norway's poverty rate was four point
three percent so that's sort of a
question mark
the life expectancy numbers cited 81
years in Norway and 79 years in the u.s.
appear to be correct infant mortality is
low
in Norway than in the United States but
I'm finding different numbers the murder
rate is lower in Norway than in the
United States with slightly different
numbers than the ones that are presented
a problematic one in my view is that
average personal tax rate number at the
bottom of the graph the effective tax
rate that people pay is not 37% in the
United States it heavily is influenced
of course by where you live and and the
cost of living of your state and how
that impacts deductions but generally
speaking most of these indicators are
correct in suggesting that Norway
appears to be better off so once we kind
of clarify some of those numbers we have
to get to some of the more subjective
claims that the graphic makes like for
example the graphic claims that higher
education and health care are quote free
in Norway I actually think that that's
sort of a problematic way to say it that
they are paid for through taxation and I
think that when we say it's free it
opens criticism of a very specific kind
which is nothing's actually free and it
starts conversations about handouts and
so on and so forth it would be better to
say countries have taxes the United
States has taxes and Norway has taxes
Norway has different priorities in terms
of how those taxes are spent and one of
those priorities in Norway is providing
health care through taxes another
priority in Norway is providing public
higher education through taxation I
think we're better off saying that then
that they are quote free because that's
both confusing not completely accurate
and also opens up a number of lines of
criticism but then we get to the most
important question is Norway socialist
and the answer is no Norway is a social
democracy in the Scandinavian capitalism
line of thinking of organizing an
economy there's a common talking point
from the right
if indeed Norway was socialist then it
wouldn't be nearly as well-off and in
order to sort of accurately deal with
that talking point from the right the
left shouldn't be incorrectly calling
Norway a socialist country because it's
just not okay and that's a really
important problem with the graphic which
is number one the United States doesn't
actually have totally unfettered
capitalism we prop up industries we
subsidize industries we have almost no
competition in many interest in
industries as I will speak with Denis
Hearn about a little bit later on in the
program and just as importantly Norway
is not a socialist country there's a
common talking point from the right when
you show them this data comparing Norway
in the United States they will say these
things work in Norway because Norway is
a homogenous white society with few
immigrants so it just works and in the
United States
it wouldn't work because of immigration
and religious a racial diversity rather
this is just wrong okay Norway has
actually the same foreign-born
population percentage as the United
States right around twelve or thirteen
percent for the last year in which we
have data for both countries so that
talking point is just wrong now it is
true that the United States has more
racial diversity in the way that we
measure race then does Norway but Norway
has a number of internal ethnic groups
groups of different ethnic background
that to us just seem as they as if they
are just all white people the way we
categorize and within Norway
these are actually more significant
differences so it's it's also just not
true to say that Norway is a completely
homogeneous country so the first thing
we have to do any time we see a viral
image like this start to spread is fact
check the data once you fact check the
data evaluate the labels that are being
attached is the u.s. really totally
unfettered capitalism is Norway actually
socialist once you have accounted for
that then we can make an analysis about
which system appear
to be working better for the people that
live within that country you should be
doing this sort of applying this
skeptical eye to every single one of
these memes that spreads over the
internet because some are accurate some
are not and we're only going to be able
to have productive substantive
conversations if we all have an accurate
understanding of what reality gives the
David Pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com let's talk about socialism
lewis we hear allegations president
obama be socialist at any time he wants
to put together any kind of policy that
helps people it is called socialism and
it turns out that this is not a new
tactic republicans have been using
socialists as an ad hominem for a really
long time and matt carp from the
american the early Americanists blog
actually wrote a really interesting
piece which points out very astutely
that if you go back to figure out when
the word socialism was first used in the
congressional record the first time that
an allegation of socialism was made it
was when a North Carolina congressman
was using the term socialism to attack
opponents of slavery
so using socialism as an ad hominem
dates back to when there was a
contingent in the Congress that wanted
to stop slavery and senator william king
of utah or i'm sorry before we even get
to that and a republican senator said no
no no banning slavery is a form of
socialism i guess because you were
limiting the the property that someone
could have in the early 20th century
senator william king of utah argued that
banning child labour was a form of
socialism then FDR wanted to create
social security which of course happened
and the american family association
opposed that saying it is an attempt to
enact a compulsory socialistic tax I had
no idea Louis that the ad homonyms of
socialism reached so far back and that
they attacked things that are so obvious
today socialism is not having slaves
socialism is not having child labor Wow
yeah it seems to be over time kind of an
amorphous term it still has a pretty
negative connotation here in other
countries it is it does not have that
and should we bring it back I mean
should we call ourselves socialists
should we try and take over here I don't
know that that's really a good idea
because when you actually think about
what socialism is I understand
conceptually the idea of kind of taking
back a word to remove the power that it
has but when the word is very clearly
defined and factually wrong I don't know
that you get the same benefit of so sort
of kind of taking the power back of that
word one other example president LBJ
wanted to enact Medicare Ronald Reagan
appeared in recordings for the AMA
operation coffee cup arguing against
Medicare because quote one of the
traditional methods of imposing statism
or socialism on people is by way of
medicine these are completely
uncontroversial today yet they were
being called socialist when they were
first proposed just like today we hear
that single-payer health care would be
socialism that the Affordable Care Act
is socialism and with Obamacare it's
even more absurd because a program that
gives 30 million new customers to
for-profit insurers is obviously not
socialist it's a it's a powerful word
and it's been used quite a bit against
Obama I think we need to come up with
another word to counter this I guess I
guess using the word itself isn't gonna
get us very far well we've heard the
idea of saying oh this is populist this
is for the people and it is for what the
majority of people would want and and
that's that's but it is though it didn't
stay it didn't stick and I don't know
that it's actually that good so we
you're right there needs to be more
language and I feel like George Lakoff
would be the guy to kind of be the frank
luntz of the left and figure out what
language should be used I just don't
think enough people pay attention to
Lake off people don't pay enough
attention to language and I think that's
one of the big problems for a long time
I've told you that in spite of the terms
liberal and socialist having pretty
negative connotations in the US that if
you fairly poll people on issues they
will align significantly with the
so-called liberal or socialist or
progressive
and we're seeing this happen now with
Bernie Sanders who's a self-described
Democratic Socialist who has of the more
progressive beliefs of all of the
candidates currently running for the
2016 presidential election and it's very
very interesting that Sanders is seen by
many negatively because of his
characterization of himself as a
Democratic Socialist but at the same
time you see that on so many issues
Americans agree with what Bernie Sanders
position is yet they still see him as
this sort of outside the mainstream
socialist guy associating that with all
of the Cold War imagery of communism and
the like let's take a few examples when
you ask Americans whether they believe
that the economic system unfairly favors
the rich 60% agree with Bernie Sanders
on that two-thirds of the American
public believe that the rich pay too
little in taxes two-thirds you won't see
that represented amongst our elected
officials you won't see a two-thirds
representation of that amongst the
candidates for president for 2016 and
even when you ask people about young
people about their opinion with regards
to socialism that is more more positive
than it has been in the past forty nine
percent of 18 to 29 year olds now have a
positive view of socialism two points
higher than the 47% that have a positive
view of capitalism we've talked about
other issues as well
two-thirds think that CEO pay is too
high more than two-thirds believe that
the government has a responsibility to
provide some basic level of health care
to everybody regardless of ability to
pay now if you go and you say hey do you
support a government takeover of health
care no you're not gonna get a
two-thirds majority if you ask it that
way when you simply ask the facts of the
matter does the government have a basic
duty to provide a simple level of health
care to everybody whether they can
afford it or not overwhelmingly the
answer is yes more than 50% of Americans
now saying that at minimum
civil unions if not full gay marriage
should be legal for the first time in a
long time since roe v wade last year I
believe it was or maybe the year before
a majority of Americans believing that
abortion should be legal in most cases
this is a very progressive country when
pulled fairly on the issues Louis but
when they get it all wrapped up in the
propaganda and ad homonyms of terms like
socialist things change very quickly and
the right has done a great job at using
language to to confuse people so I think
it's clear what Bernie Sanders has to do
he has to the way he has to run his
campaign he somehow has to get this
message across that he believes the same
thing that you believe but you know how
does he tell you that okay let's get
into audience questions for the week
first question today hey David could the
United States ever actually become a
truly socialist or communist country
this is a hard question to even dig into
because it depends on what you mean with
those terms okay so first of all there
aren't really 100% unanimously agreed
upon definitions of those systems but we
can sort of think about it in the
following way socialism is the system
where workers own the means of
production so you don't have private
ownership of businesses and in many
cases you don't have private ownership
of property although sometimes you can
have the private property but you don't
have the private businesses where all
employees own the businesses but
individuals can still own private
property you have other situations where
the government owns all the companies
but that sometimes is called communism
if it's still a profit-driven market
economy but the government owns all the
companies that's not really communism
that's more actually state capitalism
then you get to when the government owns
the means of production in a non
free-market economy private property is
often also eliminated altogether that's
the closest to the style of the Marxist
Leninist or Stalinist Leninist ideal and
that is sort of like a working
definition of what communism might be
but the quick
key question here is could this happen
in the United States I believe that
full-on socialism and full-on capitalism
are not going to happen in the United
States if ever for a very very long time
and the reason I say that is right now
first of all the United States is not a
fully capitalist country to begin with
right the US has never been a totally
capitalist system to begin with a real
lazy fair system as it would be called
government has been intertwined with the
economy subsidies taxes education
Medicare the postal service contracts
for private companies from the
government there's this endless list
where this has never actually been a
true lazy fair totally capitalist market
driven system and in that same sense the
idea that we would ever fully become a
socialist or communist nation is
unlikely from a merely structural
perspective because most countries in
the world are not uniquely just one
system they're sort of blends in some
ways the other reason why at least
anytime in the near future
total socialism or total communism isn't
likely in the United States is that
there's no major socialist or communist
party in the United States yes over the
last 10 years we've seen the word
socialism have fewer and fewer negative
connotations compared to where it was
coming out of the Cold War for example
but the most far left Democrats are
basically Social Democrats there's a
handful of actual Democratic socialists
many call themselves Democratic
socialists without actually being
socialists so there's not even a
significant clamoring for socialism in
the United States if you believe Marxist
theory then you could conceive of the
idea that there will eventually be a
sort of uprising of the proletariat
against the bourgeoisie and that you
will have a Marxist uh pending of our
system but short of believing that Marx
will be fulfilled to the letter at some
point
in the future we are more than likely
going to continue indefinitely having a
mixed system a system that has elements
of capitalism and social democracy and
even maybe some elements of democratic
socialism but to truly get to one of
those systems you would need one a a
real desire for that or if the idea is a
dictator will appear from above and
impose that you would need to first
eliminate a lot of the sort of
constitutional and democratic safeguards
that exist which would allow such a
system to come to power so I don't see
it as I've said before I believe that
the best systems are mixed full fledged
capitalism is a disaster Stalinist
Leninism is a disaster authoritarian
police states are bad I believe that
very well regulated capitalism with a
significant floor so that people don't
fall below and significant spending on
socially democratic programs is the way
forward the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show so
ben shapiro i guess has like a temporary
like a seasonal show of sorts on fox
news that's related to the upcoming
midterm election and the there has been
a segment that there have been a couple
segments actually that ben shapiro has
done one on this fox show and also in
prior programming that ben shapiro has
done about socialism or social democracy
or Marxism or communism and it's sort of
hard to tell which one it is that he's
talking about at different points and
we're gonna go through some videos and
the point i want to make to you here is
that there is sort of a deliberate
simultaneous confusion and confounding
that is being done by ben shapiro and
others this is emblematic of what many
others are doing where they are both
miss stating what socialism and social
democracy and Marxism are but also
making bad arguments against them and
there's really no better way to explain
this to you than to show you some of the
clips that we have so this is from the
fox news show that ben shapiro has been
doing and you can tell from the start
that there's just something wrong with
the presentation there's just like
fundamental factual knowledge that seems
to be either missing or being
deliberately ignored let's start with
clip number one norway has become the
favorite democratic socialist test case
for the american left venezuela people
are eating dogs in the streets and
Cuba's going out of fashion turns out
that when people are floating 1950's
Chevy's into the Atlantic Ocean that's
kind of a bad sign so the argument here
is that you've got Norway and Venezuela
and Cuba and they're all Marxist or so
he sort of initially suggests but then
later he'll kind of go back with that
and that Norway is going okay but
Venezuela and Cuba are not so that what
the left does is cherry-pick and ignore
Venezuela and Cuba and only talk about
Norway so just that one idea would be
worthy of like an hour of analysis or at
least a half hour but the main points
here are number one
shul progressives should talk about the
failings of Venezuela in Cuba I do it
all the time there are people on the
Left who hate me for that it's become
sort of like a litmus test for the the
litmus test left likes to criticize
others who talk about Venezuela or Cuba
the Leninist left call it whatever you
want but Venezuela and Cuba are
authoritarian takeovers of society with
populist left-wing rhetoric and as a
progressive social democrat I'm opposed
to that and I talk about the problems
there but then there's the real
distortion which is that anyone is
saying Norway is Marxist and Ben Shapiro
will eventually say Norway's not
actually Marxist and so the left is also
wrong about that Norway has good and bad
things going on quite a bit of good but
Norway is a social democracy in the sort
of standard scandinavian model period so
to claim that even people on the left
are saying it's marxist to even mention
norway when talking about Marxism is a
joke Norway is not even socialist
nevermind communist or Marxist and then
ben shapiro immediately goes on to say
but norway isn't actually more exists
anyway they're just a few problems with
this perspective
first off Norway isn't socialist it's a
capitalist country burdened with
massively expensive socialist
redistribution programs okay so in the
first clip he says Marxist and now he
says it's not actually socialist that's
obvious right I don't talk to any
serious people on the Left who say that
Norway is an example of a socialist
success or a communist success or a
Marxist success it's a social democracy
it's capitalism right and that is a
fundamental distortion here he also has
talked about actual social democracy
democratic socialism and some of these
same confusions exist let's look at
another clip now let's talk for a second
about the appeal of democratic socialism
because what you hear from the left of
the democratic socialism is what exists
in places like Denmark and Sweden that
is real socialism there's only one
problem none of this is true nema son
Anton ji who writes for the stream he
has a very good piece about myths
regarding Nordic socialism he's an
author and researcher heald's a PhD from
the Royal Institute of Technology in
Sweden and conducted research at the at
the
versity of cambridge and he has a great
piece about why it is that so many
people think that Democratic Socialist
Republics are the ones that are really
succeeding when in reality they're
succeeding in spite of their socialism
so here's what he says the success of
Nordic countries is based on the fact
that historically they have relied on
free markets and protection of private
property the only exception is a short
period in Sweden where in socialist
policies crippled growth and job
creation Nordic nations do have high
taxes and generous welfare but in many
other regards they have unusually free
markets that's exactly right
they have free markets they have
relatively high taxes they have lots of
social welfare programs that's not a
debunking of socialism
it's just confirming what social
democracy is right it's capitalism
combined with strong social welfare he's
acting like the writer he cites has
found some glitch in democratic
socialism arguments no it's merely a
definition of social democracy it's what
social democracy claims to be and is we
can define social democracy many ways
but it's a mixed ideology that promotes
a progressive Democratic Pro social
justice polity with a capitalist economy
period and then again he does more of
the same conflation Danish Prime
Minister Lars Rasmussen says after
seeing his country held up as an example
in the American presidential debate he
told students in a 2015 speech at
Harvard's Kennedy School of Government
quote I know that some people in the
u.s. associate the Nordic model with
some sort of socialism therefore I would
like to make one thing clear Denmark is
far from a socialist planned economy
Denmark is a market economy when it
comes to areas such as business
regulations trade policy investment
freedom vouchers in the provision of
education elderly care and health care
and partial privatization of retirement
savings nordic countries are among the
most free market in the world that's
right holding up Norway or Denmark as
socialist countries is wrong but they
are the definition of social democracy
and this is what's missing from the
conversation it is a false debate that
is being sort of framed here one more
clip hey Nordic countries did not become
rich by relying on socialism Sweden is
the only Nordic country that actually
experimented with socialism in the 70s
and 80s and instead it destroyed so it's
destroyed Sweden's economy that's right
they didn't become rich by being
socialist they became rich by allowing
for the creativity and innovation of
capitalism while understanding the
limits of capitalism in some markets
spending enough on
social programs to have as many citizens
as possible able to afford being part of
that capitalist economy because they're
not paying off medical bills or student
loans this constant back and forth
between talking about socialism and
democratic socialism and Marxism and
mixing terms and pretending to be
debunking something when you're actually
confirming at all while speaking really
fast and with an indignant tone it works
really well and on people and then
there's this really important thing that
we shouldn't forget
and finally important to note that if
you're talking about why Denmark does
better Sweden does better Scandinavian
Americans do Scandinavia does better
important to note all of these groups
when they come to America do better in
the United States and they do back in
their home countries so in Denmark
Danish Americans actually do better in
America than they do in Denmark so all
of the talk about how how all of these
countries are thriving because of
socialism is just as intro now again he
says they're not thriving in socialism
but these are social democracies and
this is really important he says Danish
people do better as Danish Americans
when they move here than back in Denmark
how you measure that is a serious
question and what does it mean to even
do better they have a higher salary here
because if that's the argument you've
got to add in when you calculate their
Danish salary the health care and the
education that they get in Denmark that
needs to be added to their Danish salary
if you really want to compare and then
you've got to adjust for purchasing
power and you've got to consider
self-reported happiness and life
satisfaction if we're just comparing
salaries if that's what we're doing it
really tells us Barratt very very little
about whether Danes do better in Denmark
or in the United States so I could go on
but the most important things are around
this issue number one don't get confused
by social democracy versus socialism
because they want you to be confused
okay number two don't let other people
tell you which system of government a
country has in the context of debunking
that system of government you've got to
figure out for yourself if they're
actually honestly representing what
system of government exists there and
then thirdly
please look this stuff up for yourself
because there are some really important
conversations happening around these
issues and if you even allow someone
like ben shapiro to set the the
boundaries and frame the debate for you
you are by definition going to come out
extraordinarily on
send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
the apartment the show was on twitter at
david pakman show the david pakman show
at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
so last week we talked about democratic
socialism versus social democracy and I
talked to you about how especially since
Alexandria Acacio cortezes win in New
York there has been sort of more and
more confusion as to what is democratic
socialism versus what is social
democracy and I did a story explaining
the difference democratic socialism is
actually socialism wants to remove
capitalism and replace it with
socialized ownership of the means of
production at least originally although
now there are people who say well
there's still democratic socialists but
they don't actually want that which
makes me question whether they're
actually democratic socialists at this
point and then on the other hand we
talked about social democracy which is a
progressive movement that wants to work
within a market economy within
capitalism and make it more of what I
call a socially guided market economy
and the difference is massive and the
confusion between these two systems is
very very problematic and the top
response that I got from people in the
audience was I mean of course other than
trolling was what's your position David
and I've mentioned before that I'm not a
socialist I'm a social democrat in the
sort of Nordic or Swedish tradition and
today I'm going to explain to you why I
am NOT a socialist and I'm happy to do
this it's something that's been an area
of study for me since undergraduate and
even even including in graduate school
and I'm going to start sort of at the
end and then we'll walk through it
fundamentally I'm not a socialist
because I want an egalitarian free
self-determining society and that type
of society will not emerge from
authoritarian apparatus and what that
means is that at the national level
socialist and communist structures are
fundamentally authoritarian and at scale
enacting socialism or communism becomes
authoritarian and a top example is
Venezuela let's assume in good faith
that the Shabbos madara goal was a truly
egalitarian free thriving Society I
don't know if it was but let's be
right and they really did want that as
the end goal when you put aside the
populist collectivist rhetoric of that
regime the Venezuelan regime is an
authoritarian imposition of government
without all sorts of freedoms lacking in
press freedom lacking in judicial
freedom it's a long list and I'm opposed
to it and whatever their intern
intentions were their imposition of
those intentions in this authoritarian
way has led to absolute disaster and
some socialists Leninists will say that
the opposition to the Venezuelan regime
is American astroturf or that the
replacement to Maduro might be worse
step back for a second an authoritarian
apparatus will not lead to an
egalitarian self-determining society
period but before we get to all of the
conclusions we need to talk about what
we mean when we say socialism or
communism
when did it start what does it actually
mean so for our conversation today when
I talk about socialism I'm talking about
modern socialism and communism in the
tradition of the 19th century and if you
go back to our socialism has never
worked debunked video we mentioned older
societies and sort of collectivist
iterations of economic arrangements but
for today we're talking about modern
socialist theory and that dates back
roughly to about the 1800s and there are
three main lines of socialist theory
almost no one who likes to talk about
socialism on the internet actually knows
about this stuff this is really
important as the nuts-and-bolts first
you had the utopians in the 19th century
these are people like Sen C Mon Fourier
and Owen and their idea was that there
would be the development of these
collectivist egalitarian sort of perfect
as the name utopian implies societies
sometimes in isolated enclaves and they
would eventually spread and I actually
do believe that individually they can
work but once you say this is the system
for the country
it becomes authoritarian in its
implementation you'll develop conflicts
between these utopian enclaves but as
usual there was some good stuff proposed
there okay their Theory applied to an
individual company or a commune or a
village it's actually a pretty good idea
I've just not seen evidence that utopian
Theory can apply to a country of 300
million for example but I'm willing to
have my mind changed after the utopians
came the anarchists the sort of second
wave second line of socialists and the
main thing with the anarchist was that
government is the problem they were
actually a lot like the more extreme
libertarians of today for different
reasons than libertarianism the
anarchist socialist saw the government
mostly as an apparatus that reinforces
the status quo of class divisions
bourgeoisie versus proletariat or today
we could say corporate versus individual
interests or elites versus everybody
else and libertarians of course oppose
government for different reasons but
there was actually a similarity there
and that also doesn't appeal to me as
most people know I'm against this on
principle I think that the government
does have a role to play but that being
said the anarchists had some valid
critiques governments often do become
pillars of support for corporate rule
they do reinforce the status quo they do
reinforce power structures I've seen no
evidence that eliminating the government
is the solution in the way that the
anarcho socialists or the libertarians
believed super-interesting that even
though now libertarians and socialists
are mostly diametrically opposed some of
the original strains of socialist
thought had a lot in common with
libertarianism they agree they don't
want central government because it's
oppressive and tyrannical but for
different reasons and then after the
utopians and after the anarchists you
get to what are now the most common
versions of socialism after utopianism
and anarchism came Marxist Leninist it
together or Marxism and then Leninism
they're not actually the same thing and
they're once again there is stuff of
value if people could realize that many
of the critiques made by socialism are
actually really good we'd be much better
off some of the solutions they proposed
have only elements of good ideas and in
Marxism its the labor theory of value
extraordinarily brilliant analysis of
how capitalism works which basically
pointed out that you have fixed costs
like if you're gonna make a product if
you're gonna make computers for example
you've got your fixed material costs
you've got the factory you need to buy
the semiconductors all of that stuff and
then you bring in workers and you pay
them something with the idea that they
add more than that to the total value
and that's surplus value you might have
in a hundred dollar computer fifty
dollars of parts and then fifty dollars
of added value if you can pay the worker
thirty dollars to add fifty dollars of
value you've created twenty dollars of
surplus value this is a great analysis
this is this is an absolutely accurate
analysis the problem is I don't believe
the ultimate solution to that
identification is the end stage of
capitalism with a Marxist revolution
that's not what I see is the long term
solution
so again utopianism i don't think it
would work at the country level but for
individual companies or communes i think
it's actually a great idea to organize
co-ops and and shared ownership great
that has worked we can apply it to
healthcare we can apply to education i
don't see that as the solution to all of
society anarchism skeptical of
government government has become a tool
of the elites in many ways we see it in
the united states with democrats and
republicans using government as a way to
maintain the status quo it's a good
critique I disagree that eliminating
government is the solution and so what
previously had been sort of a cohesive
movement but with different approaches
utopianism anarchism Marxism Leninism
eventually what we saw around the time
of Lenin was a split between actual
socialists and those who went in the
direction of social democracy and I
believe that there are a number of
reasons why social democracy is the way
forward and socialism is not and in
explaining this to you you'll identify
many right-wing arguments against
socialism which I actually don't think
are good ones and this gets to one of my
fundamental opposition's to socialism's
view of the distributions of outcomes
versus social democracies socialism in
the Marxist Leninist sort of tradition
is simply not aligned with the realities
of human distribution because when we
look at human endeavors they have
unequal distribution if you look at
athletic ability and how its distributed
if you look at linguistic proficiency if
you look at business success if you look
at human height human weight it's all
distributed on a curve and on the one
hand where socialism wants to level out
the distribution in a way that I've not
seen evidence can actually be achieved
without significant downsides what
social democracy wants to do is tweak
that distribution lower the app salute
top raise the bottom a little bit and
then reduce the gap between the very
bottom and the very top you're sort of
leveling it out you're raising the mean
and reducing the difference between top
and bottom I think it's important to
look at Sweden as an example the right
hates looking at Sweden Sweden's Social
Democratic Party which I identify with
was built on five principles that will
sound really familiar to Social
Democrats to people who follow Bernie
Sanders and those five principles were
number one an integrative democracy that
means and we can leave this up that
means that democratic decision-making is
the standard for legitimacy period real
democracy the people decide the
direction
number two the concept of the people's
home meaning solidarity and equality of
treatment as something that everybody is
committed to it there's no debate right
you need that number three
socio-economic equality and economic
efficiency are complementary these are
often considered opposing forces by the
capitalists right the the vulture
capitalists which is you can either have
an economically efficient society or one
that is more equal the social democratic
tradition actually sees those as
complimentary number four you have a
socially
Old Market economy and this is huge it's
still a market economy it's still
capitalism but the economy's direction
and the priorities are determined
socially doesn't mean society owns the
means of production as in socialism but
society guides the market economy and v
proper expansion of the public sector
expands freedom and freedom of choice
think about it health care for all
let's people get the jobs that are
actually their passion socialized
education means that people can really
study what they want rather than
deciding on the cheapest career to avoid
student loans this is all in line with
my ideology but it still exists within a
capitalist market economy that allows
for Entrepreneurship and
individualization and all of the good
things that come from the natural
diversity of people now when you talk
about Sweden and you talk to the right
they will try to destroy these talking
points and you've got to know how they
try to do it a popular went one is okay
that worked in Sweden because Sweden is
homogeneous it's all white it wouldn't
work in a diverse country this is
patently absurd okay the u.s. is 77
percent white Sweden is 85 percent white
okay the idea that those eight
percentage points are what make a system
work in Sweden and not in the u.s. is
absolutely laughable it's also funny the
hypocrisy that many right-wing or
simultaneously claimed Sweden is being
taken over by brown immigrants and it's
chaos but at the same time
Sweden works really well because
everybody is white that should make
everybody say wait wait a second that
doesn't really make sense consider the
counterpoint if the United States were
all white would the Swedish model work
it's absurd the United States is huge
and with such differences in education
and religion and so many other things
just making the US all white would not
be what either makes or doesn't make the
Swedish system works now here is where
the critique actually defends social
democracy over socialism a totally
socialist society whether Marxist or
utopian or anarchist or Leninist in the
US would actually be impossible
but what wouldn't be impossible would be
socializing certain elements of American
society health care for example very
doable large countries socialized
healthcare education education could be
put into sort of the umbrella of social
welfare in the United States that's the
Social Democratic model that I support
one other argument from the right which
is they say it works in Sweden because
Sweden is small and the u.s. is big
that's part of why I believe that total
socialism actually is not the path
forward but that there are social Liza
Balcon ponents which would work
absolutely fine in the United States so
to sort of give you the highlights of
why I'm not a socialist and I am a
social democrat I believe that a
socially directed market economy that
reduces income inequality and ensures a
real standard of living for everybody is
more realistic and it's also more in
line with human nature which actually
shows that there is distribution when it
comes to any endeavor that humans get
involved in and I fundamentally and this
gets back to the real reason that I so
vehemently oppose what we see going on
in Venezuela and what we see and have
seen in other places around the world I
do not believe because I've seen no
evidence that an egalitarian
self-determining free society will
develop from an authoritarian apparatus
period I'm willing to change my mind so
let me know your thoughts i'm on twitter
at be patent and the show is on twitter
a david pakman show and I look forward
to dialogue on this issue going forward
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
you